you're excited I can tell he looks like
I'll bouncy when he came in so I'll go
first for me it was a lot of
psychological barriers first of all
being on camera and I think you you have
shared that as well and then just sort
of channeling the rusty disused artistic
part of my brain which really only comes
to the fore when I'm under extreme
pressure and I know I have like twenty
four hours to get something done so but
that's when I felt like the most
creative so had to be a lot of pressure
though uh the second cut I thought I had
a better chance to like fix the little
things and work on like just like
putting the finishing touches I guess
probably the same other thing you got
any worse at the very least like have my
nervous leg shake
and everyone's very
I guess it would be to try not to worry
too much about the actual part where you
are on camera because it's painful but
if you keep doing it enough times
eventually you'll get a cut where you
say thank something all right
oh I would love it as a semester-long
class in particular because you know
learning editing tech more advanced
editing techniques learning more about
animation which I think for an
educational video is really critical to
convey the ideas that you want to and I
know that's one thing I didn't really
have time to do and that made me sad oh
um more less the same feeling if you
like this things that could be expanded
on but I also do like the idea that you
just have like three weeks and at the
end you've got something out of it which
is also cool